when you think Soul belly you think
barbecue right but on July 24th Soul
belly is thinking Italian Sunday supper
and we have our friends Chef Bruce
Coleman and Chef cares kuwanda back to
tell us more and and what that means
because honestly when I walked to the
kitchen I saw pasta I saw a barbecue I
saw dessert and I thought this is the
feast I never knew I needed so this all
kind of stems from I grew up in Jersey
okay okay so so this is uh some pasta I
made with Sunday gravy oh yeah and I but
I smoked the semolina for the pasta okay
and then we made fresh pasta at Soul
belly for our mac and cheese so I wanted
to make some noodles and this is kind of
merging my two worlds of Italian as an
Italian chef and then barbecue and
bringing my buddy in Chris Sexton from
hoodoo Brown barbecue in Connecticut and
my other buddy Karis to do some
delicious desserts and Chris is going to
keeping it a little under wraps on what
he's gonna do he's gonna surprise me so
not even telling you no not yet not yet
okay what do you what in your you know
professional chef genius mind could you
expect or what do you what could you
produce I think he's gonna do some kind
of like big beef roast of some kind like
an Italian beef roast okay okay so this
again this is uh this pasta is called
mafaldine okay and I made it with some
uh like I said some smoked some semolina
pasta okay I made or made pasta and then
Sunday gravy so delicious it is it's
just Sunday gravy if you ever watch The
Sopranos or Good Fellas like you see you
know it's it's a tomato sauce made with
a lot of meat and onions and garlic and
herbs and red wine
oh my gosh the smoke is just and we've
got a little bit of garlic bread here
with it because
you can't serve pasta without garlic
bread
and then some Parmesan cheese and we're
actually Gonna Bake this like melted
mozzarella cheese on top oh my gosh kind
of like a baked ziti when you get a big
ziti
we'll press parsley because that's that
dish and then I'm also going to serve uh
porchetta no go for it I don't mind at
all it's white that's why I made it okay
and then this is just a porchetta which
is a traditional Italian pork roast save
some
you're busy over there I'm getting to
you too here don't worry and uh so I
smoked these on the smokers and it's
just I just did a straight up pork belly
whoa I'm sorry I know you're talking
about that on there for you you can try
that
is incredible thank you
oh my gosh okay let's move on to cares
because I want to make sure we have this
because it looks beautiful what are we
making over there so we're making a
frozen tiramisu oh so not your classic
it's kind of like dessert Tiramisu makes
meets Ice Cream a frozen mousse
um classic ladyfingers Kahlua all that
love for for Bruce's event
and especially it just it just made
special for him that's it you're only
gonna get it at this event special for
everyone I keep telling them just for
him I love that I love that that's what
she says to me no right yeah
now really quick before I talked to JC
um reservations what should people do
um you can just go and just show up
really I mean we're not really taking
reservations it's not a ticketed event
it's just we're gonna run these items as
specials amazing about well again this
is good and I'm not talking to JC I'm
tossing a break we'll be right back